تعلق باكستان في تداعيات محاوله اغتيال
رئيس وزراءها السابق
فالمواجهه بين السلطه والمعارضه بقياده
عمران خان دخلت طورا جديدا من التصعيد بعد
ان شكك الرجل في جدول لجنه التحقيق التي
دعا الى تشكيلها رئيس الوزراء لتقصي خفايا
محاوله الاغتيال الفاشله
ماذا ستفعل هذه اللجنه ضد المتهمين
الثلاثه بمحاوله قتل طالما هم في مناصبهم
وتعملوا تحتهم اجهزه امن سيتعين عليها
تقديم ملاحظات لتلك اللجنه كيف يمكن لتلك
اللجنه تعمل باستقلاليه وشفافيه والمتهمون
يشبهون على عملها هذا مستحيل لذا اكرر
مطالبه باستقاله المتهمين الثلاثه يتم
اجراء التحقيق حقيقي
المتهمون حسب خانهم رئيس الحكومه شهباز
شريف ووزير الداخليه رنا صنع الله وضابط
استخبارات برتبه لواء يدعى فيصل ناصر لكن
الحكومه والجيش
اعتبرتهامات خان مجردا كذيب وهدد بمقاضاته
بتهمه التشهير
وبينما تتمدد الازمه الى قطاعات حساسه
بينها الجيش والاستخبارات والقضاء كشف حزب
انصاف الذي يقوده خان ان السلطات
الباكستانيه اوقفت عشرات من مؤيدينها خلال
مشاركتهم في وقفات تضامنيه مع رئيس
الوزراء المصاب منذ تعرضه الخميس الماضي
لاطلاق نار في مدينه
شرقيه باكستان وبعد ثلاثه ايام من الحادثه
غادر عمران خان المستشفى عائدا الى منزله
الىهور لكنه حرس قبل مغادته على كشف خريطه
طريق لحركته الاحتجاجيه المطالبه اجراء
انتخابات مبكرا اكد ان المسيره الحاشده
ستستانف الثلاثاء مسيرها نحو العاصمه
اسلام اباد
وسيقودها وزير الخارجيه السابق شاه محمود
قرشي الى ان يتعافى خان من اصابته والامر
قد يحتاج الى نحو اسبوعين على الاكثر قبل
ان ينضم خان الى المسيره ويتولى قيادتها
ثانيه عند وصولها مدينه والبندي على مشارف
مركز القرار في اسلام اباد